wir leben in der tiefen Wirtschaftskrise
es hat jetzt jeder aus dieser
Perspektive aus seiner Perspektive
beschrieben und jetzt erleben wir
mittendrin eine flüchtlingskrise wieder
in diesem Winter Herr Marquardt
was glauben Sie wie die Deutschen da im
Moment drauf reagieren übernehmen wir
uns also ich glaube dass wir bei der
Situation ja momentan betrachten müssen
wer kommt da eigentlich wer ist dieses
Jahr gekommen und das sind zu 80%
Menschen aus der Ukraine ja vor allem
Frauen und Kinder und die haben
natürlich jetzt auch in einem Land wo es
nicht besonders viele Kapazitäten für
solche Katastrophenfälle gab und wo die
keine resilienten Strukturen da waren
dann erstmal auch Unterkunft brauchen
müssen das war so dass viele privat
untergekommen sind das toll wie viele
Leute sich da engagiert haben die die
Gesellschaft auch mit dem Menschen aus
der Ukraine zusammengehalten hat wir
sehen jetzt aber dass diejenigen die
sonst auch noch kommen die kam die
letzten Jahre auch dann eben wenig Platz
finden und das ist auch in den Kommunen
wirklich wenig Möglichkeiten gibt dort
die Menschen anständig unterzubringen
wir wollen ja immer wieder für die Leute
die einfach sagen wir würden gerne aber
wir haben einfach kein Platz mehr wir
haben keine Wohnung mehr Frau Schinken
sie werden das kennen aus ihrem
Wahlkreis aus den nachbarwahlkreisen wie
würden Sie die Stimmung dort im Moment
beschreiben
bei ja einer lässt sich immer noch von
Willkommenskultur und aber gleichzeitig
bei einem ganz starken Gefühl Mensch wir
haben so große Probleme vor der Tür die
Stimmung wir schaffen das gar nicht also
wir erleben schon eine große Solidarität
in Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern gegenüber
ohne Frage aber die Leute nehmen
natürlich auch zur Kenntnis dass wir
eine eine steigende Anzahl an illegaler
Migration haben in Deutschland und dass
wir vor allen Dingen eine
Bundesregierung haben die wirklich ein
Paradigmenwechsel in der
Migrationspolitik vor sich hat und den
hat sich auch vorzunehmen und auch
umzusetzen 12.000 etwa illegale
Migranten im Moment pro Monat Herr
Marquardt nehmen Sie das war ist das
ganz offen ein Thema in der
Bundesregierung oder ist das was was man
gerne gerne unter Tisch fallen lässt
nein also das nimmt man wahr und da muss
man sich auch anschauen aus welchen
Ländern kommen die Menschen die da
kommen das sind ja vor allem auch Länder
in den Krieg herrscht Syrien Afghanistan
zum Beispiel sind die
hauptherkunftsländer momentan es gibt
dann so einzelne Situationen wo man
jetzt auch glaube ich schnell
diplomatischen Druck braucht
beispielsweise ist so dass in Serbien
relativ viele Menschen aus Indien nach
Serbien kommen und dann über Österreich
auch weiterreisen dort Asylanträge
Stellen Menschen aus Indien bekommen am
Ende kein Asyl die haben auch das
rechten Asylantrag zu stellen aber muss
dann schnell jetzt mal mit Indien und
Serbien reden warum das eigentlich so
passiert dass es auch Teil einer man
kann sagen russischen Strategie dort
bestimmte Menschen in aber auch künftig
kein Asyl mehr
um da Bleiberecht in Deutschland zu
bekommen ist ja schon als gedulde da
können sie mit geringeren Anforderungen
ein bisschen Deutsch Sprachkenntnisse
und ein bisschen
Integrationsbereitschaft und schon
können Sie in Deutschland bleiben das
ist das was die Ampel hat uns gesagt ich
bin froh dass sie das Thema mal
anschneiden weil ich glaube dass es in
den Medien und in der Politik zu klein
behandelt wird das Thema Migration da
wird in den Talkshows stundenlang über
diesen Ausrutscher von Friedrich Merz
geredet sozialtourismus richtig oder
falsch aber das Problem wird nicht
besprochen ich kenne viele Bürgermeister
und Landräte die sind verzweifelt die
illegalen sind das Problem wer politisch
verfolgt wird kriegt bei uns Asyl dass
sie dem Grundgesetz da steht jeder zu
aber unsere Nachbarn in Serbien beinahe
Nachbarn und der Schweiz die schicken
uns die Leute rüber da müssen wir was
gegen tun da muss die Regierung und den
Grenzen zu machen gegen illegale
ist ihre Partei ist ihre Parteichef zu
still geworden nachdem er da so gebascht
wurde wegen seines sozialt
nein wir sind überhaupt nicht still wenn
sie letzte Bundestagsdebatte zu diesem
neuen Gesetz was da geplant ist verfolgt
kann dann haben sie sehr sehr deutlich
gesehen wo unsere Haltung ist also wir
haben das sehr sehr deutlich gemacht wir
haben genau gesagt wie erfolgreich oder
eben auch erfolglos die
Integrationsbemühungen waren wie hoch
der Integrationswille ist wie viel
Menschen auch tatsächlich arbeitslos
sind unter den hier lebenden Migranten
und was ausziehen ist das Friedrich Merz
das in dieser Sendung gesagt hat danach
gepasht wurde und dann das Thema für die
Union eigentlich erleben in Deutschland
überhaupt kein Interesse daran diesen
Problemen mal nachzugehen und das mal zu
untersuchen ich ganz ehrlich ich rede ja
auch mit den Menschen in diesem Mann sie
hören alles sie hören alles sie haben
große Bemühungen
Integration zu fördern die Menschen zu
helfen sie haben aber auch ganz andere
Berichte sie sie hören und erleben alles
und ich führe diese Diskussionen täglich
aber wir können es nicht festmachen wir
können es nicht an online festmachen
weil in diesem Lande kein Interesse
daran besteht Probleme auf den Grund zu
gehen man will es nicht wissen und das
ist der Vorwurf den wir machen und an
der Aussage von also man kann über die
Aussage von Friedrich Merz sicherlich
streiten ob sie richtig platziert war ob
sie richtig formuliert war aber wir
müssen über diese Dinge reden ist
wichtig ja natürlich nicht dieser einen
Spruch und das wird und sind wir mal
ganz ehrlich wir haben wirklich wir sind
der sozialste Sozialstaat den es weit
und breit gibt auf dieser Welt würde ich
jetzt mal einfach so in den Raum werfen
wir sind diejenigen die die Regeln
machen in diesem Land die Politiker
machen die Regeln in diesem Land und
wenn wir damit eine bestimmte Folge
Wirkung erzielen bei allen Menschen auf
dieser Welt dann brauchen wir uns
darüber nicht wundern also wenn wir was
geändert haben wollen dann müssen wir
die deutschen Gesetze ändern und dann
wird sich eine Situation
drin wenn jemand aus einem sicheren
Drittstaat kommt dann brauchen wir den
nicht aufzunehmen
machen der glaubt mittlerweile keine
mehr dran dass das wirklich
funktionieren wird weil wir seit 25
Jahren gekommen sind bedeutet aber das
dass diese Diskussion und dieser
Eindruck dass wir uns den Problemen
nicht stellen dass das dazu führen wird
dass wir bald selber hier in Deutschland
eine Frau Meloni wählen werden also wir
haben ja die Situation erstens dass wir
sehen die Menschen hier aus der Ukraine
fliehen die fliehen nicht zu großen Teil
nach Deutschland sondern die verteilen
sich eigentlich ganz gut nach Frankfurt
da könnte man auch mal dran arbeiten
auch einmal Kong mal dran arbeiten
die Situation ist aber nicht dass die
Leute wegen der Sozialleistung aus der
Ukraine jetzt nach Deutschland findet
dafür einfach keine statistische Evidenz
dann hat man die Situation ehrlich
gesagt dass das deutsche Recht eben
nicht so einfach ist dass man im
Grundgesetz mal einen Artikel liest dann
macht man die Grenze zu und sagt du
darfst hier nicht reinkommen sondern man
muss erstmal schauen im dublin-system
welcher Staat ist eigentlich zuständig
dafür ist die Person dann also welche
Gründe hat sie dafür dass sie an der
Grenze ist sie muss also ein erstmal
rechtsstaatliches Verfahren durchlaufen
selbst mehr Einreiseverweigerung nach
dem Schengener grenzkodex braucht sie
erstmal Papier man kann nicht einfach
sagen die Grenzen sind jetzt zu bis bald
tschüss da finde ich da machen wir uns
das so einfach weil es hat bestimmte
Gründe und das ist alles komplett
begrenzen müssen mit den deutschen jetzt
sagen wir begrenzen diese Zahlen sowie
was auf dem Höhepunkt der
flüchtlingskrise mit der Obergrenze
gemacht haben also gab ihr nie eine
Obergrenze aber wir haben ja durch auch
die hundertprojekt 300.000
oder 2017 die Obergrenze wir haben keine
irreguläre Migration oder nicht ganz
kurzes Schlusswort wir kommen ans Ende
dieser Sendung wir kommen Grenzen oder
nicht wir müssen das gut organisieren
also nicht begrenzen die Grünen wollen
nicht begrenzen denn man kann das
Asylrecht nicht begrenzen